how's it going everybody welcome back to
the cosmic wonder I'm your host Warren
and the MCU is getting really really
exciting right now with a lot of new
characters about to enter the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but also a lot of old
characters that are going to be entering
the MCU for the very first time Deadpool
3 Avengers Secret Wars and possibly
Doctor Strange 3 could bring us some
Ultra Cool variants that we have yet to
see in the MCU and among these awesome
variants that are going to be entering
the MCU are the original X-Men now we're
not sure which variants these are going
to be but we do know that the original
X-Men cast most of them are returning
for Deadpool 3 and hopefully sticking
around for Secret Wars we know that
Wolverine's going to be sticking around
Hugh Jackman and maybe some others will
stick around as well and with so many
characters about to be in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the ones that we
currently have the original Avengers
that are still around the new Avengers
that are going to be coming and the fox
X-Men and other old original Marvel
characters like Ben Affleck's Daredevil
there are about to be a ton of
characters in the MCU which means we're
going to have a lot of different teams
and we've heard recently that they're
actually going to be three different
Avengers teams when we go into the King
Dynasty and into Avengers Secret Wars
now there are probably going to be many
different groups that we see throughout
these two films and possibly even in
between but three Avengers teams just
make sense for what secret Wars is going
to be about especially if you consider
the fact that Kevin feige the president
of Marvel Studios has already teased Us
by telling us that there are going to be
multiple sides of the MCU we have the
street level Avengers team the cosmic
team and the supernatural team that's
just for the regular MCU but what does
that mean for Avengers Secret Wars where
the Multiverse is going to essentially
be blown open anything is possible in
the Multiverse and any character showing
up is possible as well which is why
Secret Wars is so exciting it is
literally Limitless and while the amount
of characters and teams that we could
have is Limitless I believe that these
three different Avengers teams are going
to be for for a very specific purpose
and it just so happens there are three
main Kings to look out for the Kang Trio
or the Council of kings and it could be
that each Kang requires its own Avengers
team to take on now from the
post-credits scene of Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania we were introduced to
the Kang Trio and the Council of kangs
now just to clarify the Council of Kings
is one a group and two an event that
takes place the Council of Kings is not
the thousands of Kang variants that we
saw in the Ant-Man and the WASP post
credit scene rather the Council of Kings
is a select few Kings who get together
to essentially determine the fate of the
Multiverse so in the MCU the true
council is most likely the Kang Trio
that we were introduced to this includes
immortus Rama Tut and the Scarlet
Centurion now the Council of Kings does
also in part consist of the other king
variants the thousands of King variants
that we saw however it is ruled by the
Kang Trio and this is how it is in the
comics as well the council is originally
formed by Prime Kang but in the MCU it
looks like mortis isn't charging in the
comics immortus is the one with the plan
to betray all of the other kings and
make sure he is the last king standing
so I'm sure we're gonna see something
pretty similar here and they call
together the Council of Kang's this big
event where all of the Kings come
together so they can basically explain
what they want and get the other kings
behind them and basically get them to do
their will Ken could really truly
dominate the entire Multiverse however
there is one big problem when it comes
to Kang and Kang's variants and that is
Kang himself no matter which variant of
King it is they will never trust any
other version of Kang and ultimately
want for themselves to be the only King
standing and the true ruler of the
Multiverse that's why we think that our
King Trio here is secretly against each
other and they have their own plans and
they're going to try to execute these
plans and we're gonna need a team of
Avengers to stop each one of them in
fact even if they do manage to actually
really come together and trust each
other which it's already kind of been
shown that they don't trust each other
based on the way they were kind of
bickering and snapping at each other in
the post-credits scene for quantumania
but even if they came together they
still have different roles to play and
that would still most likely require an
Avengers team for each of them so the
question is which Avengers team is going
to take on which variant of Kang well we
know that we're going to have our main
New Avengers team coming from our main
Universe in the MCU this Avengers team
will include characters like Sam
Wilson's Captain America Spider-Man our
new Falcon Joaquin Torres Shang Chi
She-Hulk and possibly even Daredevil
we've heard rumors that Kevin feige
really wants Daredevil to be a part of
the new Avengers team so that'll most
likely happen but as you can see this
isn't the most super powered Avengers
team there is Sam Wilson won't have the
super soldier serum neither will Falcon
we do have She-Hulk who was going to be
a Powerhouse but Shang Chi also doesn't
really have that great of powers without
the tin Rings based at least on what
we've seen in the MCU so far and as far
as we know their 10 rings are King
Technology so he could take those back
or possibly even control them leaving
shangshi without the tin rings so since
they're not super ultra powered perhaps
they're best fit to take on Rama Tut now
we don't really know what Marvel Studios
is going to create as far as the
background for the king Trio but in the
comics Rama Tut is essentially the first
version of Kang the Conqueror that rules
or conquers anything when Nathaniel
Richards finds the time travel device
the first thing he does is go back in
time to ancient Egypt and becomes the
Pharaoh Rama Tut and he rules over Egypt
that is the first variant of King so if
that remains true for the MCU perhaps
Rama Tut that Kang variant will be the
let's say the least tech savvy which
could be why r our main Avengers team
would be more fitted to take him on then
we have the Scarlet Centurion when Ken
goes back in time to rule Egypt as
ramatut eventually the Fantastic Four
defeats him and drive him out he
attempts to go back to his own time but
gets stuck in a Time storm this forces
him to go back to a modern era of Earth
the main Earth 616 Universe where he
runs into Doctor Doom who is believed to
be his ancestor Dr Doom convinces him to
drop ramatut and essentially become more
like Dr Doom and that's how the Scarlet
Centurion is formed so naturally just by
the progression of things this is a more
advanced King than ramatut so it would
require a more advanced Avengers team
and this team is most likely going to
consist of characters from our main
universe but also from the Multiverse as
well this is where we get our more super
powered Heroes and most likely the job
for some X-Men as well to be a part of
the Avengers team this includes Heroes
like Thor Captain Marvel the Hulk shuri
as the New Black Panther Deadpool
because of his healing factor and then
some X-Men like Wolverine storm Cyclops
so a little bit more of a heavy hitting
team but then we have a mortis who is
most likely going to be the most
advanced version of Kang and therefore
the strongest and he does seem to be the
leader of the king Trio based off of
what we've seen from the post-credit of
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania the
Scarlet Centurion even asks him how many
of us did you call telling us that
immortus was in charge he's the one who
called the council and he's the one who
decided who they were going to call and
in his words he said he called all of us
so all of the different versions of Kang
and as we saw their reaction from the
audience they looked super pumped to see
the king Trio so we know that these
three kings are the strongest versions
of Kang out there so it's safe to say
that if a mortise is their leader he is
most likely the strongest version of
King period in fact in the comics there
are actual time Keepers I know they were
revealed to be fake in Loki season 1 but
in the comics the timekeepers are real
and they eventually go to Kang and ask
him to be their agents they go to him
from the end of time itself and they
tell him that instead of destroying
timelines he should preserve them and he
becomes their agent and he reinvents
himself again calling himself a mortise
because the timekeepers grant him
immortality for becoming their agent so
in the MCU this is most likely the
longest living Kang so therefore he is
probably the most advanced King and this
means that he'll have the most advanced
technology out of all the kings but he
might also have some Powers it is
possible that he could have learned some
type of sorcery or witchcraft so the
threat of this King could not only be
that he has amazing Tech and weapons but
he could also be what we'll call
enhanced if you live millions of years
you probably get your hands on some
pretty cool stuff I wouldn't be
surprised if he actually took some super
soldier Serum at one point in time as
well that's just an example of what he
could do with the technology that he has
to travel throughout different points of
time also don't forget he can literally
go to the Future sure and grab weapons
this makes him extremely dangerous we
already saw how strong King the
Conqueror was in quantumania literally
being able to freeze people in time and
essentially erase them out of existence
as well this Kang is even stronger than
that King so it's gonna take a pretty
big and powerful Avengers team to take
him on so this is probably where we'll
get characters like Professor Xavier Dr
Strange the Scarlet Witch maybe Jean
Gray in the Phoenix Force maybe some
different versions of Iron Man and Mr
Fantastic because if you're dealing with
a very Advanced Kang you're gonna need
the smartest man alive there and
probably his wife his brother-in-law and
his best friend as well the entire
Fantastic Four team we know that
different heroes are going to be
fighting in different universes until
they eventually if this happens come
together in one Universe because of all
the incursions this could be where they
come together as one big fool Avengers
team and yes we are grouping other
characters and teams into Avengers it's
pretty much just like what happened in
Infinity war and Avengers in game and
infinity War we had actually two
different teams of Avengers kind of
three if you want to count Thor in the
Guardians of the Galaxy doing their own
thing for a little bit in the beginning
but basically we had the Avengers team
on Titan which insisted of non-avengers
like Spider-Man although Tony Stark did
make him an Avenger right before they
fought and Dr Strange who was not an
Avenger and then the same thing goes for
the battle at wakanda we had our
Avengers team there but we also had
black panther of course it was wakanda
he was not part of the Avengers at the
time and then of course Thor ended up
joining with the Guardians of the Galaxy
well part of them rocket and group the
other Guardians were on Titan so it's
pretty much gonna be the same concept
different Avengers teams fighting
different battles except at another team
and perhaps add even more considering
the fact that we're going to be dealing
with multiple different universes here
in multiple different teams but this is
something that I absolutely cannot wait
to see because I think it's going to be
just super exciting if executed properly
and also some characters might even jump
groups and help with other battles as
well until they all eventually come
together just think of the portal scene
in a Avengers endgame but on a way
bigger scale on one side you have the
X-Men coming out the other side you have
the Fantastic Four coming out then on
another you have an Avengers team coming
from the earth 616 universe and then
another Avengers team from the earth 838
universe and so on and so forth all of
these heroes from the past the present
and future coming together to defeat
Kang the Conqueror and the Kang variants
it is super exciting to think about but
let us know your thoughts about this in
the comments down below does this excite
you and what do you think about the
different teams of the Avengers who
would you like to see on which team let
us know your thoughts in the comments
down below also don't forget to
subscribe and leave a comment because
this enters you in a giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items and some DC
items as well the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each month don't forget to like the
video and follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf
foreign